splatoon 3 takes everything nintendo
learned from two games and a large scale
expansion and then adds even more to
make a robust ink-soaked package variety
isn't necessarily the first word that
comes to mind with the splatoon series
but it certainly will be a key element
of splatoon 3 with two games and a large
scale expansion under its belt the
latest in nintendo's kid-friendly
shooter franchise builds on everything
that came before that means a game
that's loaded for bare more game modes
weapons maps customization features and
more having tried three of the modes at
a preview event the game looks robust
while remaining very recognizable for
splatoon fans at a hands-on event i
tried three distinct modes that showed
the breadth of the content offerings in
splatoon 3. the single-player return of
the mammalians campaign the cooperative
wave based salmon run and the
traditional competitive turf iv battles
and although each relies on the same
basic mechanics playing them all back to
back in quick succession showed how
ingenious and flexible those mechanics
are to support very different
experiences return of the mammalians is
the third installment of the ongoing
splatoon campaign series a weirdly
colorful post-apocalypse that has long
implied that the squid kids and
octolings emerged post-humanity this one
focuses on the fuzzy mammalians
including fuzzy hazards that can trap
you temporarily the name seems to imply
that this could answer some of our
questions about what happened to
humanity but the handful of early stages
i tried didn't venture into that
territory instead return of the
mammalians was a good warm-up activity
letting me get a hang of the weapons and
movement again after being away from
splatoon like the other two game single
player modes it serves both as tutorial
and stand-alone adventure centering
itself less on combat than the
multiplayer modes and more on
environmental puzzles none of these felt
terribly challenging but it was a good
opportunity to get my sea legs the
single player mode was also a good
chance to try one of the new weapons the
stringer bow though a bow might seem
straightforward enough the splatoon take
on the weapon adds versatility that
takes some finesse to master which is
not to say that i did you can squeeze
off standard bow bolts quickly but
holding down the tension lets you toggle
between two additional functions a power
focus shot and an explosive shot mapping
these functions to the length of your
drawback is sure to raise the skill
ceiling for high level play next up was
salmon run the cooperative horde
multiplayer where four squid kids fight
off saminoids while gathering their eggs
and tossing them into a centralized
bucket in a small arena setting in
splatoon 3 salmon run will be available
all the time instead of only during
special limited time events nintendo has
noted that there will be special salmon
run events that will occur on a regular
schedule but you can dive into a match
and fend off some angry fish anytime you
want and those fish can get very angry
for the sake of comparison we played two
rounds of salmon run to experiment with
different difficulty levels with the
modifier set at five percent and then
fifteen percent though we finished both
rounds handily absolutely filleting
those fish the difference between the
two was stark the five percent modifier
was a relative walk in the park or swim
in the pond while even the 15 difficulty
made for some harrowing moments where
taking down the deluge of enemies was
like swimming upstream with more enemies
and more frequent boss battle
appearances it was easy to see how this
will create longevity with plenty of
room for elite squids to challenge ever
more aggressive saminoids finally we
tried three rounds of turf war the
traditional competitive multiplayer that
splatoon has always been built around we
had free reign to experiment with
different weapon types and the sheer
volume was a little overwhelming this
was every weapon i remember from
splatoon history and some i'm sure i've
forgotten for the first round i tried
the other new addition the splatana a
sword style like windshield wiper that
can also do a short range burst if you
charge ahead of time suffice to say i am
far from a splatana samurai perhaps a
live competitive event isn't a place to
try a brand new weapon but i found the
splatana hard to utilize effectively i
did get an occasional kill by sneaking
up on opponents to close the gap but its
charge shot was no match at a distance
against weapons built for range which is
almost every other weapon in splatoon so
when it came time to swap weapons before
next round i hastily put down the
splatana and went for a more traditional
splat gun that embarrassing spectacle
aside turf war is just as enjoyably
chaotic as ever it's easy to forget how
brilliant the core competitive gameplay
of splatoon really is your weapons are
offensive but combat is incidental as
the true goal is to cover as much of the
battlefield as possible with ooey gooey
neon paint with a beautiful wet sheen
that in turn lets you travel quickly in
swim mode to reach a hot zone escape
from an enemy encounter or sneak up on
opponents it's such a beautiful
self-sustaining loop of system none of
this is new to splatoon 3 this is how
the series has always worked but i think
it's worth taking a step back to
appreciate how harmonious it still is
between turf war rounds we got to
experiment a little with the new lobby
system which serves as a testing ground
for weapons and a social hub to see your
friends represented as holograms you can
test weapons out on a series of dummies
to see weapon damage too which may be
useful for competitive players even with
the wealth of options though we still
didn't see everything we didn't try the
block puzzle minigame table turf battle
which combines a collectible card game
with filling in spaces on a game board
with tetromino style pieces to claim
territory as an overhead approximation
of filling the battlefield with paint it
looks like a clever idea and i'm looking
forward to trying it then on top of all
these modes there's everything
surrounding the game that we saw in the
recent nintendo direct presentation the
wealth of customization and
communications options include
decorating your squid kid or their
locker posting messages for other
players exploring the city and more we
didn't see any of those elements first
hand but they're kind of the little
flourishes that help you round out the
experience nintendo has already outlined
that it has a two-year plan for in-game
events and catalogs to collect new
fashion options to give it legs or
tentacles as the case may be thanks to a
wealth of gameplay options that have
been refined over the past games and
expansions alongside a few new additions
splatoon 3 looks to be the most robust
splatoon package yet the underlying
mechanics still feel as great as ever
but now there's just way more to do with
them
see you next time at gamespot